Well, you guys know we love Airbnb. I also just did a ladies' birthday trip. It was my friend's 50th birthday. All of us gals drove up the coast. It was so fun. We had the kitchen to hang out in, but then we all had our own space because, you know, we love each other, but I mean, I kind of want my own space at night. You know what I'm saying. We love the privacy. They're always in such great locations where you can really get to know the town you're in. And there's some real hidden gyms out there. These little pockets and neighbors, that you might not see if you stayed at a hotel. Listen, I could go on and on about Airbnb because I love it. It's a great way to travel with friends and family. And you know, your home might be perfect for Airbnb. If you frequently travel or have extra space, maybe you go out of town at the same time every year for a family trip, your home could earn you money while you're away. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.ca.com. Hey, office ladies fans, Jenna and Angela here with some exciting news. Our holiday merch is here, and we are so tickled.
You know Angela spearheads our merch, and she has once again designed some adorable stuff. We've got brand new party planning committee sweatshirts, so you can plan your next holiday party in true Scranton style. Yes, and they're super comfy. And don't forget, your very own office ladies ornament is perfect for your tree or your desk or a gift for all your friends and family. Angela pulled some very funny office quotes for the ornaments. Well, there were a lot to choose from. But listen, hurry, because these holiday goodies are only available from November 5th through 12th.
And some of our selected items from our last merch pop-up are still available until they sell out. So hurry and go check it out. Head to shopofficeladies.com and grab yours before they're gone. Happy holidays. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hey there. I'm very excited about today's episode. Same lady. We have been wanting to have this guest. on for a long time. And it finally happened. Jenna, you want to tell everyone who we're talking to
today? Well, yes, we are talking with Tig Nataro. Remember when we broke down Test the Store in season eight, we were not able to speak with her. And we got a lot of mail. I want to read you some. Kimberly T. from Utah said, please, please interview Tig Nataro for this episode. Your podcast and hers are two of my favorites, and I'm dying for a crossover. And Abigail D from Boston said, special guest star alert. I absolutely love the sitcom queen Tignitaro as Tiffany's mom. She's also been in episodes of New Girl, Instant Family, Community, and Fresh Off the Boat, such a talented stand-up comedian, and I was just so tickled to see her do such a
great job on this show. Way to go, TIG. Well, we were so excited when TIG was on set when we filmed this. We were thrilled she was going to be part of the office. We were big fans. We're still big fans. And as Abigail said, TIG is a stand-up comedian. She's an actress, a writer, producer, podcaster.
She's been nominated for a Grammy Award for her album Live. And her special Boyish Girl Interrupted was nominated for an Emmy Award and a Grammy. She has written several stand-up specials is a favorite on late-night talk shows. And you can see her in many television shows and film. Most recently, you can catch her on her new comedy special. Hello Again. That was directed by her wife, Stephanie Allen. And she's on the morning show, Star Trek Discovery, and she is filming Star Trek Starfleet Academy series now.
You asked her a lot about it, Ange. Angela really geeked out on the... I mean, this is a huge, huge show to be a part of. It's a big deal. And we also got a lot of mail from you all about it. Yeah. She was also in Justin Noble. and Mindy Kaling's show Sex Lives of College Girls on Netflix.
Well, Mindy is a very big fan of Tig. We shared when we broke down Test the Store that it was Mindy who requested Tig for the role of Tiffany's mom. Yeah. And I went back and rewatch Test the Store's superfan episode on Peacock. Tick's scene has an extra couplet of dialogue, and it cracked me up. I thought we should hear it. Now, if your attacker is willing to defile a corpse, you better stop playing dead right away
And just make it known that you're alive. Forgive me for interrupting. I believe my daughter had an altercation with somebody here. Some fancy gentlemen with a squeaky voice. I think you guys might have the wrong office. That's him. The guy I hit. What?
What? You've got to be kidding me. Poor Andy. First you got beat up by a gang, and now she kicks your ass. No, Kevin. What about the lady you hit with a pine cone? There, that chubby one. I just had a baby.
Yesterday. Wow. Apologize. Sorry I kicked your ass in front of your thin girlfriend. How about we wait till next year after you have your kid? You know what, Tiffy's going to college. Listen, I don't know what you guys are talking about, but I guess I'll just accept your apology so we can get on with our day. Sorry I punched you.
And I promise I'll take it off Facebook. It's on Facebook. There we go. God bless. A friend of mine uses your paper. is your paper. You do good work. Bye-bye. Bye. I'm so glad you played that, Angela, because, well, you'll hear in the interview, but TIG has a very unique point of view of shooting that scene that is so funny.
Yes, her memory of filming it is hilarious, and it's a piece of information neither of us knew. She's never shared it before. But I love the extra couplet of dialogue about the fact that her daughter had uploaded it to Facebook. Yes. Further humiliation for Andy. Yes. Well, everyone, why don't we take a break? Why wait any longer?
And then when we come back, it's our interview with Tignitaro. Yeah, let's do it. I want you to take a second and become aware of the smell around you. Does it smell like kind of like nothing? Do you smell something? Scent has this amazing power to influence the energy of a space or express the individuality of a space. It can enhance your mood and your feelings.
And Pura wants to tap into that positivity of scent. Pura makes the coolest diffusers, mini diffusers, larger diffusers, and they have a gazillion cents available. So if you want to walk into your bathroom and have it smell like a tropical vacation, you can have that. If you want to walk into your kitchen and have it smell like the holidays or like fresh baked cookies. And right now, Pura is having a special promo where you get a free Pura set when you subscribe. Subscribe to a festive scent now and easily swap it later. This exclusive deal won't last, so shop now at pura.com. What's up, guys? It's Candace Dillard Bassett, former Real Housewife of Potomac.
And I'm Michael Arsino, author of The New York Times Bestseller, I Can't Date Jesus. And this is Undomesticated. The podcast, where we aren't just saying the quiet parts out loud, we're putting it all on the kitchen table and inviting you to the function. If you're ready for some bold takes and a little bit of chaos, welcome to Undomesticated. Follow and listen to Undomesticated, available wherever you get your podcasts. Hello there. Are you talking to me? We are.
Oh, okay. I wasn't sure if, like, you needed to do a little something and then talk to me and then. Oh, we'll do that. Okay. But we don't make you sit through it. Okay. We're like, hey, we've got a great episode for you today. Yeah.
TIG is here. We did that already. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. But we're super excited to see you. I am very excited to be here. here. TIG, we asked our listeners to send in questions for you, and we're going to ask you
some of their questions. Okay. But I have to share that when I was going through the digital mailbag, I have not forever in the five years we've been doing this, seen the kind of letters that you inspired from people. And we've talked to a lot of people, TIG, have you? This isn't episode one. It's our news spin-off podcast. We got a lot of not questions for you, just letters from people expressing their enthusiasm for you, and I'm going to read you one. That's so nice. I thought it would be a good way to kick things off. I hope it's a long letter. It's not. It's a short one. Okay. But it's great. I'll still hear it. It's from Rebecca D in Edinburgh. Hi, Rebecca. Rebecca said, Tigg, why are you so amazing?
How do I become more like you, and where do I sign up to be your friend? I don't have any questions. I'm just looking forward to hearing y'all chat also f cancer that is very nice that letter we got over and over again with slight differences but but it was rebecca every time it was Rebecca you are tricky I'm like Rebecca D from Edinburgh again but with a different accent in her writing spelled Rebecca different a few different ways you are beloved oh that is kind that's It's very nice. Thank you for embarrassing me. I know. How do you do with like praise like that? Because I always like say something like, you're like, oh, your hair looks nice. I'm like, I didn't wash it. Yeah. Like I can't. Or, oh, nice Christmas pajamas. Oh, they're clean, I think. I think.
That's from earlier off my convo. You guys, I dropped things off to the school this morning in Christmas pajamas. Yes. Don't judge me. And I tried to get to this recording today and circled the building many times and drove everybody behind me crazy. But we're here. We're here. And I drop swimsuits off for my sons today. This is what you do. That's what I do. I know. Yeah. Well, we are so happy to have you here. And, you know, we broke down this episode that you're on, test the store during the strike. And we couldn't talk to you then because, you know, we were following the rules and whatnot. But we always start our interviews and we ask people, how did you get your job on the office? Well, I went in an audition and I'm not a big auditioner, not because I am a
fancy person. It is really the opposite because I'm not good at auditioning and I don't really identify, or I haven't. I'm starting more so identifying with acting, but I'm a stand-up comedian who have, you know, I have friends that have TV shows and I ended up on them. And then it just kind of has kept happening. And I'm almost, I'm like 25 years into acting. And I still tell people, I'm like, oh, no, I'm not an actor. I'm a stand-up comedian. And so I did happen to audition for that because it's like, oh, it's the office.
I'm going to go give that a whirl. And then I got it. Which is not, it's, I usually get a job if I don't audition. Because I'm typically taking space or taking a cop suit. Right, yeah. You know, so that's why I don't audition. I like thinking of you like that now. I'm like, tigs in the car.
Yeah, that's right. Circling the building. Yes. Well, we know that Mindy is a huge fan of yours. Well, I remember afterwards Mindy was saying, oh, when you came in to audition, I was like, oh, we got a higher TIG. And so I don't even know if my audition really mattered. So maybe it was because Mindy liked me. What was your experience like when you came to set that?
because this was early in your acting career. Oh, yes. You've done Sarah Silverman, which is a little bit more sketch comedy, I guess. How was this? Because you were in the conference room with everybody, staring at you. I was. And I told you before we started that I wanted to apologize ahead of time for my experience on the office. Okay.
It was everybody was very nice to me. Okay. This was all my doing. this goes back to me, not really identifying with being an actor. And I also want to back up and explain something about myself that people always kind of roll their eyes and go, it can't, not really, but really, I don't watch, I don't follow TV and film, okay? I follow music and documentaries. We've listened to your podcast, Handsome, which is hilarious.
And so we know this about you. It is very true. So, like, I mean, you didn't know who Selena Gomez was. Yes. I said, Lena? Yeah, I know. And it's true. Yeah.
Like, even the other, I produced this documentary where my friend who is, like, a hardcore, like, hairy armpit activist in the mountains of Colorado, didn't know, acknowledged on the documentary that they didn't know who Mary Kate and Ashley Olson were. And Stephanie was like, there's no. My wife, Stephanie said, there's no. there's no way Andrea doesn't know. And I said, Andrea is like doing massive activism, living in the mountains. And I'm sure they really don't know who Mary Kate and Olson is. That's what I said. Mary Kate and Olson.
And the 70 was like, what did you just say? And I was like, what did I say? And she said, you said, Mary Kate and Olson. And I was like, okay, so if I said that and I work in Hollywood, chances are my friend in the mountains does not know who Mary Kate Nolson are. So anyway, I just wanted to give that backstory. Okay. And now comes the embarrassing, mortifying part. Okay. You're on set. I'm like, I've learned my lines, which is a whole task for me. I mean, getting my lines down, I'm in a panic and always. I go on to set and I hadn't ever seen the office, okay? Okay. And now I'm
I'm on set filming the office. And I'm, as you said, in the conference room with everybody, I realized I didn't know who the characters were. So I didn't know who to direct the lines to. You didn't know who Pam was. I didn't know who anybody was. And it didn't dawn on me while I was learning the lines. And then when I walk in and I see everybody and I had to see Andy with the Shiner. I see everybody, and I'm like, I don't know who.
And I was directing my lines in the wrong direction, and I was corrected. And they're like, you're looking at, and I was like, oh, my God, get me out of this situation. You know what? You had so many options. I have people. There's so many people. And I was just going on a wild, like, like, looking at it. You know what?
You know what is so funny? You remember this? Well, now I will say this. I watched that there's the super fan version of it now on Peacock, right? And it's pretty much the same as the original broadcast. There's one or two more couplets of dialogue. But now that you said it, because it's very fresh in my mind, at the end, you look out at everyone and you look at people and you go,
you make good paper here. And like, you're looking at. at the accountant and like, you're sort of, your, your gaze is kind of like dear in headlights. Oh, it was. Like, because you have no idea who's making the paper. And I went over this with my wife. I, uh, when I was getting ready for bed last night, I said, Stephanie, I'm doing, uh, office ladies.
And I've seen the office since then. My kids got really into it when they were four. They're now almost nine. But, um, so I'm getting ready for bed. And I said, I'm doing the office. office ladies podcast tomorrow. Do you think I should share that? And she was like, I don't know. And I was like, I said, I find it hard to believe that they would take it so personally and be upset with me. And she was like, yeah, you know, I'm sure it'll be fine. But she said, this morning before I
left, she said, make sure you let them know that you have changed and you research now before that, you know, that you're not that same person. So that's my secret on the office. I was absolutely mortified. It felt like one of those moments in life where you're like, I got caught. No, nobody knew. No one knew. It reminds me of the dream, like the anxiety dreams you have.
Acting anxiety dreams, do you have those where you're like, oh my gosh, I have a role and I have to deliver a monologue and it's now and I don't know it and I don't know any of these people. Like that, I've literally had the dream that you lived. I haven't had those, I think, because I don't identify with acting. So there's not even that anxiety. Like, I just don't. You have so much you say on Star Trek. And it's like, it's like engineer speak. And I mean, I one time auditioned for a sci-fi.
I don't think it ever made it. And I was so unbelievable. Like, I love your character because I believe you. I had to say something. Well, because it's TIG in space. Why wouldn't you believe me? It's taken space. I know.
I tried a new version of Angeline's space and it didn't work. I had to say something like, and it was so ridiculous. I was like showing my scar. And I lift up my shirt and I go, got that from a tick tick and sector four. Like, I still remember it. I did not get a call back. Oh, this was an audition? Yes, it was an audition.
Oh, for a show that now you think didn't go. I don't think it went. I'm catching up. Yes. Okay. I wasn't even listening. Okay. No, that's not true. But I'm just saying you do well with like big speeches. You are an actor now. I'm, here's the thing is I was on a show called Star Trek Discovery. Yes. That
wrapped up and ended. My character jumped over to a new Star Trek series that I'm currently filming. Starfleet Academy. Starfleet Academy, starring Holly Hunter. I know. I know. I'm so excited about this. I have a question for you. Go. I didn't want me to enter and Trent. Paul Giamatti is the villain. Incredible cast. I have really struggled with Star Trek dialogue. And on this series, I have a bigger role. And so there was more dialogue. And I was really feeling down on myself because I was like, I'm struggling.
And, you know, I'm on a show with these incredible actors. And it really, I was thinking, I need to, like, step it up. And Stephanie said, I'll put you through my boot camp. but you have to follow everything I tell you. What's her boot camp? Memorizing boot camp? She was saying, essentially, I'll teach you my process, but you have to do everything I tell you. Okay.
And so I did that. I was in Toronto working. I saw a new side of my wife I hadn't seen. We've been together 12 years, and she was no joke. She was so intense and serious about doing this, making it work. And I have to say her process has changed my life. I mean, I had done all the typical things of running the lines over and over. I wrote them out a million times.
I did it with other people or I would record myself saying the other side of the lines. And I was struggling. And her process has made everything so much easier for me. And I'm excited to do not just Star Trek. And this came at the end of season one of this new show. I can't wait to go back to just a regular show where you say, hey, see at the party, and, like, use her process because I even struggled with that kind of thing. I can tell you, Jenna, is geeking out right now.
I haven't even looked at you, but this one loves a process. Yeah. I love a process. I didn't care, but, like, I would be on those, you know, Emmy panels with the morning show. And I'm up there with, like, Jen and Reese and John Hamm, all these people, Billy Crutup, and they're asking them about their process. And then I used to try and kind of fake it to be. And then I just, I went rogue one day.
And I was like, I don't have a clue what's going on. I'm struggling through the whole. And I'm like making jokes. And I thought for sure people were going to be like, you got to. But they were all so amused. And they were like, we're bringing you on every panel. Because I just, I stopped after that first time. trying to pretend like I was, you know, really, I can't compete with those actors that are up there.
But now. But now I'm excited. If they put you on a panel, you are not going to be all joking. I have a process. You have a process. You have to share your wife's process. I mean, not here. You can save it because I'm sure it's like, I don't want you to have to share her process if it's special. No, I'm happy to, especially if it helps somebody. But she basically said when you get your sides, which for people that maybe don't know, No, it's just that scene that you're going to be doing, and it's not the whole script. It's just your scene. She said, read it through, and then write out or type out only your dialogue. And that way, if you get 10 pages, you don't panic thinking, oh, my God, I have 10 pages, because you're just looking at your dialogue, and you'll see maybe only have seven lines in the 10 pages.
And it can really give you an idea like, oh, I don't need to panic because I just have these seven lines to learn. And then she said, just learn only your lines. Get it to where you can say it basically like an entire monologue. And then once you have that down, then plug it back into the script, to the sides that you have. And then you're fully off book. That's fantastic. And I was like, wow. And she said, and when you've removed just your lines, you can see, oh, I do have a lot of lines, or, oh, I actually don't have that many. And that helped me personally.
Right. It's less daunting if you can just see what your part is. Yes. Yeah. And it was easier for me to plug it back in after I isolated things. What do you think of that process? I like it. Do you? Yeah, I do. I might try it. Yeah, I really, it got me so excited, whereas before I'm in a panic, every time I'm on set, and I'm not a panicky, nervous person, but I felt like an imposter, you know, whenever I was on set, because I don't identify with being an actor, and I don't have a process. I'm just scrambling every time. But you are TIG, and you're TIG in space. I'm TIG in space. I'm TIG in the office, and I'm directing my lines to all of the wrong people. And that was just a night. It's been a secret I've carried around for a long time. I'm so glad you could get rid of that.
You're done with that. Well, I don't ever want to come across as disrespectful. Well, yeah. But now I think time and my career, I'm caught up and I'm like, okay, I'm an actor. I'll say it. Fine. I'm an actor, especially now that I have a process. Oh, yeah.
We got a fan question from Linda B. in Riverside, California. Hey, Linda B. Who wanted to know, were you a Star Trek fan before joining the cast of Star Trek? Well, the original series, my brother and I were both into, and we had all the action figures and things like that. But I didn't follow it after I was like five or something. And then my friend Alex Kurtzman, he took over the entire Star Trek universe and
has helped EP and create all these shows and he and I worked together at, you know, the director Sam Ramey at his company. I was an assistant there. He started out as an assistant and then became like a showrunner
and I went off and did stand-up full-time. And then he brought me in for a meeting and I thought I was going to do an episode or two and then I ended up just being a recurring character on Star Trek Discovery, but after the first episode, I really struggled with my lines. And I called
Alex and I said, I know you said you wanted to use me as much as you can. And I, in my mind, I thought they'll probably use me once or twice and I'll go away. But I said, I want you to know I struggled really bad. And if you don't want to use me as much as you want, I was, yeah, I was like, truly don't feel like you have to hold yourself to that. And he said, if you're having trouble with the lines, I'll just make them even harder. Oh, no. What? You just, you know, a friend giving me a hard time.
And he's like, and he also said, and your character will never die. So that's not around the corner. So you're in. Buckle in. Yeah. Oh, that's so great. Yeah. But now it's so fun to be in the.
Star Trek world. My gosh. I have to ask you about Holly Hunter because I just love her. You know, I'll never forget when she was on Inside the Actors Studio, you know, they ask everyone their favorite curse word. And people just sort of say shit or asses for her. And she just looked right at him and said, cock sucker. And I was like, what?
That is brilliant. And I don't even really know that I really heard anyone say that, like out and about in the world. You have not heard people say that. that time, I was young. Oh. And I just remember being like, yeah. Yeah. I don't know what maybe early 20s. And you had not heard anyone. We're not buying it. No, this seems. I was not familiar. Like, I mean, it was like, Holly's not going to buy that. Oh. No, for real. Like, I remember being like, I'd heard a lot of like curse word, but I was like, cuck sucker. I don't think of that one. That's like, that's fantastic. It is a unique favorite.
Curse word, I'll give you that. Anyway. This is, you guys mentioned nerding out, and this feels kind of nerdy about the way you're discussing that word. Oh. Yeah. Like, you saying it, like, being like, I hadn't really heard that much. And you're saying, yeah, whatever you were just saying, it just felt very nerdy around an unnerdy word. I know.
Well, anyway, I just remember being so surprised by it. And now you get to work with her. And I'm worried that someday if I meet her. that I would have that moment where you just go blah, and I just say something like, I love it when you said cuck sucker. She's going to be like, what are you talking about? No, she would probably hug you for like two minutes. She's very affectionate too. Aw. I mean, she's the commander, right? She's the captain. Yeah. She is the top dog, and she is, man, she's just incredible and she's also so fun. Like before I left Toronto, we had gone out
for lunch that went five hours no yes yeah yeah that's so cool i mean she's she's an incredible actor and she's a serious actor and she's also so fun and so fun to laugh with you know oh i bet and talk to and she's one of the most curious people i think i've ever met and this i'm always like oh this sounds so weird to say because of course you should be nice to everyone But that's not always a case on sets, especially with somebody as well known and celebrated. But she knows the entire crew's name, their jobs, speaks to everybody, sits down like two inches from their face so interested in their lives. That makes my heart so happy. Yeah, yeah.
It's really a nice thing to come across in this industry. So, I have, I have. We're going to pivot. I don't know. Hold on where we're a pivot. Well, we'll cut our whispers. Why would you cut the? I don't want any whispers. Pivot whispers. I don't. I got it. You got it. You got it. You found it. You found it. Okay. Is it the watch? We're not at the watch yet. Everybody, we're going to do a, we're going to do a question about Tick's watch, but we're not there yet. Okay. Okay. Stay tuned. Should I go to my full voice again? Yes. Okay. You found your pivot. I'm not going to.
Stay there. I'm going to stay here. Yeah. I'm going to have a cup of tea. Okay. Okay. Tigg, there is a thing about you that is famous, which is that you talk slow. Yes.
Yes. You even did a whole bit where you tried to get an auctioneer to train you to talk fast. Yeah. Very funny. Thank you. We reached out to the director of your episode, Test the Store, Brent Forrester, and he sent in an audio clip about what it was like directing you in the episode. And I want you to have a listen.
I'm sorry. Should we have given you a heads up? It's hilarious. Oh, my gosh. You probably can see where this is going. For the part of the little girl's mom, Mindy always pictured Tig Natara. We didn't audition anybody.
We just offered it to Tig, and she was great. But at the time, I was concerned about the pacing of the scene. And after the first take, I walked up to Tig. And I said, hey, TIG, I have a thought. And she said, you want me to talk faster? And I said, yeah, how do you know? And she said, every time they put me on camera, they tell me to talk faster. And I said, can you talk faster?
And she said, no, I can't. Do you remember this exchange? I feel like it is an exchange I have on every set. Every set. Like, in fact, it's gotten to the point where when a director comes towards me, I'll put my hand out and say, before you give me any notes, just know I have no range. But go on. What were you going to say? I just, but it's always getting to that of like, okay, and now let's do it faster.
And, you know, and I try. But, you know. I just think the beauty in your comedy is your pacing. I just love it. And I feel like I couldn't imagine you tell a story not the way you tell it. Yeah. It's, it's, you know, there's a lot of talk about how just the connection between music and comedy and a lot of musicians want to be comedians. A lot of comedians want to be musicians.
and so much of that, I don't know, the timing. Like, it feels like a rhythm and a song to me. The way, like, I can't, the way I deliver my material, it's not thought out. It's just the natural beat and rhythm of the story. And people have asked me, do you decide to pause there for two seconds? or do you decide to,
and I'm like, no, there's no thought. It's truly just how I deliver it. Have you always had that cadence? I mean, I've always been, you know, told I was, yeah, slow and dry, but I think it's highlighted on stage in front of an audience, but it's not on purpose. Mm-hmm. I know just back when I did a ton of improv, you know, you would do a workshop and you would teach these young improvisers.
And I always sort of felt bad saying this because I was like, oh, they're all here to learn. But you can't teach timing. You can teach a lot of things, I feel like, for comedy. But timing is just something instinctual, I think, personally. I do too. And it's a very different timing on and off stage as well. I think that it's just highlighted a little more. Yeah.
Yeah. We got a fan question from Natalie L. in Boston who says, I love you, Tigg. Did you get to practice with the actress who played your daughter prior to the shoot day? No, I did not. I was going to say, I wish I had, but I don't even know. Did you know she was playing your daughter? No, I'm kidding.
I honestly don't think I knew anything. Is this person? Yeah, like, why is she stealing my thunder? Why am I referring to her? Get out of my scene, kid. Yeah, no, I didn't run it with anybody. And is this upsetting to the office fans if somebody is like, oh, I hadn't seen it? Um, you know what I mean? Like, I, I know there's rabid fans where they might be offended or something.
No. Oh, that you hadn't seen before? No. No, because we've had a lot of different guest stars. Some people were like, I was so nervous because I'd seen every episode. Yeah. And then other people were like, I knew it was a big show, but I hadn't seen it yet. Yeah. Yeah. No. And everyone's experience is completely different. So no. You will not offend anybody. You'll be fine. But I do, I want to mention again that I have seen. many episodes of the office because we were just blown away that our four-year-olds were just like so into it. Do they have a character that they were most like? A lot of little kids like Dwight. Yeah, I was going to guess Dwight. Yeah, it was Dwight. Yeah. Yeah. And I know who Dwight is. Rain. You're not just saying, sure, sure, yeah. No, for sure. For sure. We also have this question from Colton S and Vincent, Ohio. Hey, Colton S. Colton S says, did you break at all during the scene? Did you crack up? If so, who made you break? You might not know.
Who made you break? You'd like describe them. I mean, no, I have to say I, I mean, I think I, I'm always amused by Ed Helms. Yes. I mean, he is such a silly man. And I know people know that, but I think he's even sillier than, I don't. I don't. know. I think once you know Ed and then you see his silliness, it's a tickle, it's a deep tickle. So I can just, I don't have a great memory, but I can just assume, I know he was sitting in the front row. I'm just going to assume I was tickled, but I was more so on edge, like terribly on edge that day, because I really, like I said, felt caught. Did you know Ed before you shot on the office?
Yeah, not well, I think just through Largo of him doing shows there and I did as well. You're right, though. He is really silly. He's so silly. We used to do the stupidest bits. And I know that I could call him right now and do this stupid bit and he would do it right back. Yeah. I told him this story one time about this girl from my hometown who, if she really liked you, she'd be like, hey, stupid fucking twad. And Ed lost his mind and still to this day, we will say that to each other. And he does it right back the same way. And I'll have to do that too.
Oh, my gosh. Yes. But you've got to do it. Like I'm going down a country road. Yeah, like she's laughing. Like between cigarettes, but. Yeah, he's, I think he's, even though people know he's, he's a comedian, I still think he, it's surprising how silly, deeply silly that man is.
Yeah, in the best way. Well, Ed Helms famously introduced you for your comedy set that you did that went on to be nominated for a Grammy where you talked about. being very recently diagnosed with breast cancer. When we broke down this episode, I didn't know that I had breast cancer. I had breast cancer, but I didn't know that yet. And so when I listened to your special, I was so moved and I sat in my car just weeping and laughing. It was this cathartic thing and very shortly after that, I was diagnosed with breast cancer and I spent all last year fighting breast cancer. I am now in remission and cancer free. That's amazing. But I just have to say that I just have to say thank you for that because I went back to it
And it was your line where you say that comedy is tragedy plus time. I thought of that so many times in the very early days because I was like, no, I'm just in the tragedy. Yeah. But there will be time. Yes. And maybe, maybe there will be comedy again one day. Yeah. And so, yeah, what a crazy thing.
Yes. And thank you for that. And I'm so glad that you're doing well. And I want to also make sure, and I tried to make it clear in the special that like that isn't my line. I just was repeating a line. Yes, that's like a famous line. But to have you like apply it to your recent diagnosis was so. brilliant and um i was i was just rock bottom in tragedy yeah and also trying to immediately do
comedy and um and i did not know how it was going to go um just like i didn't know how nobody knows how life is going to go yeah and the audience in the beginning when you said i have cancer at first they didn't know what to do with it they sort of laughed and then and then my god you just had everybody in the palm of your hand it was so honest It was just really beautiful. Well, thank you. I always say it was truly the exact, everybody was perfect in that audience. It was, they carried me through because I had never shared such personal, I mean, when I was diagnosed, I thought I wasn't going to tell anybody.
And I remember calling my manager and saying I have cancer and I don't, I don't want anybody to know. And I had, I mean, just to even back up, I had, prior to that, I had pneumonia. I had this intestinal disease called C. diff that's deadly. It ended up killing my stepfather a couple of years ago. And then I also had cancer. My mother tripped, hit her head and died. My girlfriend and I split up. And then I was diagnosed with cancer. And that was in four months. And I, I, I, I just, I, and it was actually shortly after I had met you, because I remember, I was with my girlfriend at the time, and we had all had a really fun time and exchanged numbers and, you know, and then, and then all of that happened. But, but, yeah, when I went on stage, I just was highly aware of how quickly life and health can just slip away, just gone. and I was at a point in my life and with my health where I couldn't just take a Tylenol or something and turn my health around.
I was just, it was terrifying. So when I went on stage, I thought I love stand-up so much and I want to do it one last time if this is my, I didn't know what was going to happen to me because I was, my body was fighting so much simultaneously. And I had no idea what was going to happen with that. I had no intention of releasing that as an album. It just was all kind of a crazy experience, how it all went down. Did that change your approach to your comedy moving forward? Did it become more personal? I mean, everything changed, but yeah, I opened up in so many ways.
I was so private when I was hospitalized with C-Diff, you know and Sarah Silverman only meant good but she had shared pictures of me to another comedian and I was like you don't show her anybody I'm so you know and she was like oh my God I didn't even think about it because I I would share that about myself and I was so closed off and private whereas now I'm like I would I feel like oh yeah I looked like hell I was on my death You know what I mean? Like I don't care when I was first with Stephanie. I had a medical emergency and was in diapers, like walking around in front of her. Like, you know, I kept joking about making like a crinkle, crinkle noise when I'm walking around. But like I just, all of that made me let go of so much. And but then also trying to find the happy medium of I've shared so many things, whether it was through stand-up, I wrote a book, I wrote a TV show, there's a documentary about me, there's so many things. And I realized that I don't have to make myself completely available or share every single thing all the time and talk about silliness.
I love silliness and I love lighthearted ridiculousness. And so after that time period, I was so thankful and I went on tour and I met with everybody after every show and thanked every – I felt so supported. And then I also realized, like, I'm not really that personality that can sustain this, you know, for this long. And I do direct people to the stuff I've put out. and also sometimes I'll share things, sometimes I won't. And sometimes I'll talk after a show and sometimes I'm just going to go back to my hotel room. And so it's been a whole process of trying to figure out where I am and what I'm going to do or share because I am an earnest person, but I'm also a very ridiculous person. I'm really relating to a lot of what you're saying.
I'm kind of hanging on your every word. because I'm also a really private person, and I did not share about my cancer diagnosis for a year. And so I've only just shared, like, last October, and I sort of feel like I'm in that place that you're talking about, about the outpouring of support, and now I do want to talk about it a lot. In fact, in some ways, because when I was going through it, I wasn't emotionally processing it at. at all. It was just, I had to just one step in front of the other. And every time I got through one thing, like when surgery was over, chemo began. And when chemo was over, radiation began. And so I now have my port out and I've done all the big things. I'm just on like a medication that I'll take for five years, which is what's giving me the hot flashes, which is why I keep taking
my coat on and off in this interview. And because you're terribly indecisive. And I can't decide if I want this coat off. Yeah. No. I can't. Is this the fit? Yeah. Is this the fit? It's both things. Yeah. And they're working against each other.
But yeah, I think now I've only had time to think, oh, my God, what just happened? Yeah. What the fuck just happened to me? And so I'm doing that same thing where I'm figuring out, like, well, how much do I want to talk about that publicly? How much do I want to talk about it privately? Mm-hmm. I don't know. It's a lot.
Sure. I mean, it took me a long time. You know, I was backlogged with emotional distress. And because I was so guarded in my life, I remember, like, the news had come out that I was sick. And then as soon as I had a double mastectomy and the doctors felt like they had gotten everything under control, I wanted immediately to go on Conan and share that I'm okay. Like, I didn't want anybody to think I'm not okay. I'm, you know, I'm moving along. Everything's all right. And that was kind of how I was going through life.
And I took a job and I was working on a TV show. But meanwhile, my mother just tripped and died. And meanwhile, I still have incisions like stitches across my chest while I'm working on this new show and I don't have a primary relationship. and I just, I was so lost and confused, but I was, it took me a while to really catch up with what was going on with my body and my mind. And I remember I moved back to L.A. after working on that job and I sat on my couch and I felt like I was going to fall off of the planet. I don't know if it was a panic attack, but I didn't feel stable on the couch. And you know, it's crazy.
This is also very odd to tie it all back. March 1st, I am confident, is when my episode of The Office aired, and that was the first time I got any symptom. I remember I was home with my girlfriend, and my throat hurt, and I wasn't feeling well. And I just thought I had a cold or something, but I had gotten bronchitis or something, and then it turned into pneumonia. and then I had gone to get antibiotics, and that is what caused me to contract C-DIF, and then it just kept going and going and going. But March 1st, I sat and watched the episode of the office, so I did finally see an episode of the office. But that was the beginning, March 1st of 2012, was when my life just started to slide away,
and my mother died on March 28th, and I was hospitalized mid-mart, like right now. I was still hospitalized with C. diff. But anyway, so it just took me a very long time to catch up because once I went through and had my surgery and I moved out to New York to work on this show. And I just was trying to keep things going. I'm fine. I'm okay. No problem. I can handle anything, you know. I remember. The moment you got still is when I almost fell off. It all caught up with you. The face of the earth. I truly was like, what is happening? I felt. it's so unstable. Yeah. Yeah. I totally get that. I also had this desire as soon as I told everybody that I was being treated for breast cancer. I wanted everyone to know I was okay. Yeah. I didn't want people to worry about me. And I also, I wanted people to know that I could still work. Yeah. I was really afraid that no one would ever hire me again. Same. You know. That's why I called my manager. I remember sitting in the parking lot. I had a loft downtown at the time, and I called my
manager, and I said, do not tell anybody, because I really was so scared that people would take work from me. Yeah. That's so sad, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, because I know what a worry that was for you, Jenna. And she went to such great lengths. You know, we had all these meetings. We were changing, you know, we were starting to meet with Odyssey, which is who we're with now for the podcast. And we had all of these Zoom meetings. And Jenna created this wig hat. It was like a baseball cap with a wig that you. It had like my, my hairstylist came up with it.
It's, you know, almost like a mullet hat. I was like, why can't I take my old hair extensions and glue them into a hat? Yeah. And she was like, you can. And you guys, what do you call you had a name for it? We called them wiggets. A wigget. And I had four.
That's amazing. I had different colors, so I could switch them out. And then I also had these headbands that had hair. So I could put those on as well. I also had wigs because my hair was falling out, but I hadn't told anybody. So I did have some, like, awkward school functions where, like, a hat wasn't really appropriate. Did you have any... But I wore it anyway.
Did you have any headphone wigs? No, for podcasting. I didn't. I didn't. But that would be perfect. kid's school and you're like, sorry, I'm running late. I have to record the podcast. I just forgot. Oh, are these still on? Yeah. Anyway. Well, I don't want to take them off now. No, because my hair will look weird and it is my hair. It really is. No one. Don't be concerned.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Nothing is seeing here. Yeah. No, but we would, I would sometimes just on Zoom, I would just like put the camera in a way. Yeah. So that you couldn't see the top of my head. And then I could just wear the headband wig. I started wearing hats and I'm not meant to wear a hat. No. It makes, I just kind of look like a kind of a short, like budgy man. I don't know. My face is so round. Like I put a hat on and I'm like, like, I'm like a little, I'm like a little tortoise. This is not true. She has a thing where she does braids with a hat. Because without the braids, I just look like a little tortoise man. A tortoise man. Yeah, I'm a tortoise. I look like a tortoise man with or without a hat.
I get called, sir. Oh, ladies. Excuse me, but everywhere I go, I'm called sir. Yes, I answered a lady. We are not calling ourselves tortoise men on this podcast. All right, all right, fine. We are going to be kind to ourselves. We are office ladies.
We are not tortoise men. Thank you. We are. That's the spin-off. We're handsome ladies. Yes. Yes, we are. But, no, we did.
We wore a lot of hats. And I just, I was just, whatever, Jenna and I've been down this road a lot because it's hard not to get emotional when you don't know how to be there for someone you care so much about. Yeah. You know? Well, I mean, but that is what you do is you just show up to be with your friend and whatever comes with that in that moment. I remember my big experience, I guess, as a young adult was my very closest friend from my childhood who was all. also the godmother of my kids, her sister killed herself. And I was so scared. And I called my mother. And I was like, what do I do? And she said, you hang up the phone with me. You drive over to
her house and you just sit with her. And I was like, yeah, okay. And I did. And it was so hard and it was so uncomfortable. And it was all of these things. But it changed my life. And I am, man, do I live by that rule. Like, I will be there. I will absolutely be there. And I always think any hard thing I go through, I'm going to be alive after this uncomfortable thing. I'm going to be alive after this hard phone call. I'm going to be, I'm going to live through this. It's just going to be really hard. It's going to be really uncomfortable. But nothing feels better than hanging up the phone, driving over. and just being with somebody that you care about. And I had incredible friends. I don't know how you, you know, handled or went through and how, whatever. But I was like on lockdown. I didn't want any peripheral friends.
I didn't want, I just wanted my people. Your inner circle. Yeah. Yeah. And that was it. And I just really struggled with. opening myself up, but I feel like I've done both, aside from being there for people, allowing people to be there for me. Yeah, I had a really great group of very supportive friends,
and those were the people that we shared with. Yeah. But I didn't share very widely. So there were a lot of people that I do consider to be my friend who I did not share with for a long time. but I needed those people. I needed there to be like moms at the school who didn't know who just came up to me with like school gossip, you know, people who weren't talking to me about cancer and how I felt. Yeah. And so I love them for that, for not knowing. And I also did have some people who I told who I thought would show up for me and they didn't. Yeah.
They didn't have the capacity to come and be with me in this, and I forgive them. It's okay. Same. It's just some people have that, and I think it was just whatever so real or scary for them that they couldn't do it. And that's okay. And I'm still friends with them. I, one million percent, experience the same thing.
And it was that learning curve in life where you go, I know they love me. Yeah. And I know they're not able to do this for whatever reason. And it, but I did at first get my feelings hurt. I did too. And then when I really thought it through, I was like, this is not because they're a bad person or they don't care about me. They just don't have that ability. And then there were the people that surprised me as well.
The people who I had maybe thought weren't going to have the capacity to go through that with me. And they did. And I'm, wow. It's really mind-blowing when that happens. Yeah. Just puts everything under a magnifying glass, I would imagine, right? Yes, everything becomes more in focus. When people step into a really messy, terrible, rough situation, and they're not.
Not. I mean, that's already a big deal when it's your crew. And then when it's somebody just a little outside or even a lot outside, and they're like, I'm here. Let's go. Yeah. Yeah. It's really incredible. Yeah. Yeah. Well, switching gears. As we do. As we do. You are such a multifaceted artist and we got a lot of fan questions about your work. multi-faceted. I like that word. I want to be a multi-hat. Like, what is it called on Wikipedia when you have multiple paragraphs? A multi-hyphenate? Yes. You're a multi-hyphenate.
Yes, I want to be that. You are. You are. Both of you are. We've got some hyphens. We do. We have one or two, not as many as you. You're hyphenates? No, you're super hyphenate, though.
Okay, back to you, Tick. Emily P. Indianapolis said, TIG has been in so many things, but I wanted to know what her favorite project is. I just love when she comes up on my screen. I think the office is the first place I saw her, but I love her stand up. I love her on Bob's Burgers, on New Girl. I loved her in the movie Instant Family. There are so many options, but I want to know what TIG enjoyed the most or is most proud of. Well, it's sadly not the office. What? How dare you? I was proud of it. I was proud of it. I was proud of, to be on there, but I was not proud of my work any time. And what's so crazy is some people only
know me from the office. Do you get recognized a lot? Yes. And I can't believe when people come up and they're like, oh my gosh, I loved you on the office. I'm like, what? It reminds me of, but it's also, obviously, that show is so enormous. Yeah. You know Kate McCutche and Ricky Linholm. They were Garfunkel and Oates, musical comedy duo. Okay. I don't know them. Okay. Well, very funny. They're no longer performing as Garfunkel and Oates anymore, but Can we find them on the internet? Yes. Okay. And it's, it's, uh, is it delightful? I can't wait. It's so delightful because they're both like fresh, sweet-faced singing, not so fresh, sweet-faced. Okay. Okay. And, uh, but,
Anyway, they had a TV show on IFC for a while, and again, friends that had me come on their show. And I was in one scene, very short scene, and I was going to Florida to work out material for my upcoming special. And so I was just doing a few quick club dates. And when I got there, the poster said Tignotaro from Garfunkel in Oates. That was my one credit. And it was clearly somebody that worked at the club that just was not familiar with me, Googled me. That was the first thing they saw. They just slapped it on.
Way to go, buddy. And it's like, no offense, IFC. I don't even know if that exists anymore. But I'm certain maybe 50,000 people watched IFC. IFC, you know? So anyway, I was very excited to do the office. I was very flattered. I was very honored, but I just did not do anything I was proud of.
What have I enjoyed? That is really a hard question. It is. It is really hard because it's like mentioning instant family. I was a social worker with Octavia Spencer, And we just had the greatest time. Rose Byrne, who is this silly, I mean, I love her. She is a freak of nature, her talent between drama and comedy.
I can't even stand it. I love that. But, you know, I do. I have a lot of pride, even though I struggle through my lines doing Star Trek. And I'm now, as I mentioned before, I'm more excited to approve. myself now that I have a process. A process. And that fandom, that is, I mean, it's like the office. That rival's the office. No, it's, it's bigger. It's because it's just been around for so long and you're part of that universe now. I mean, William Shatner is almost 100 years old. I think he's
95. And he still jets off every weekend to a convention. And I mean, have you seen this guy talk? Yes, I saw him on, I forgot the late night talk show, but he was like doing bits. I mean, this guy has no clue. He's almost 100. Yeah. Like somebody needs to tell his face this because he's just like walking around like he's not 95. You can take the weekend off. Truly.
You can put your feet up. Yeah. Yeah. And then I also, I have a small part on the morning show. And it's really fun to do just like a. dramatic, you know, yeah, show. Fast-talking drama. Yeah.
And I've known so many of those cast members in so many different ways over the years. And so that's fun, too. Part of what I enjoy about acting is this really highlights how much I'm not an actor, but when they say cut and then I get to talk to. Then you get to do the chitty chat. Then I get to talk to my co-stars. That is one of the best parts of being an actor, is just existing. with all of these, like, incredibly creative, funny, interesting people.
Yeah. I mean, artists and actors are interesting. Yeah. Yeah. So, I don't know. Those are the two things I'm working on these days that I'm fresh in my mind and I'm enjoying them. Those are decent, you know. They're not too shabby.
Yeah, I've really enjoyed everything. Like, I, you know, there's been some rotten people in the mix here and there. but in general, I've had a really great run. Can I ask you about the watch now? So in your new comedy special. Hello again. Directed by your wife. She was nominated for an Emmy.
Stephanie Allen. Yep. Fantastic. I loved your special. Thank you. I couldn't help but notice that you have on a fantastic watch. Thank you. And I asked you when you came in, I want to hear about the watch.
And you said there's a great story about this watch. And I'm sorry I didn't notice the watch. Oh, that's fine. I thought the lighting was beautiful. Well, thank you. I was like, oh, there's a story because I was thinking how it ties in also to cancer. Oh. Years ago, I was guest starring on the Sarah Silverman program, and there was an actress that came on there that I had a really fun banter with an exchange to the point where I was like, geez, cute.
But I was like, she's not into me, so that's fine. She was engaged to marry this guy and whatever, but I still thought she was so funny and it was just fun every time I saw her, worked with her. Years go by, and then I run into her right before I'm moving to New York to work on that TV show, and I hadn't been diagnosed yet, but we were at a table read together. A friend of ours was doing a Broadway play. wanted us to read through this script with her. And afterwards, we found out we were both moving to New York at the same time.
Well, she was divorce now. And we exchanged numbers. And, well, it turns out there was something between us. And then I was diagnosed in the middle of that. And I was very insecure because I was like, oh, my gosh, I can't believe this woman that I thought was so attractive and fun, and I'm getting her attention now. And now just buzzkill, I just got diagnosed with cancer. And she was so good to me during that time and helpful.
And then I had my surgery. I didn't have reconstructive surgery. And so I do still just have scars on my chest. And I remember also feeling very insecure about my body for a while. And when I talked to her about that, she was like, I love scars. I think scars are so hot and sexy. And I was like, what?
I was like, well, I got something to offer you. I got scars. I got scars all the live long day. I was like, you like scars? And she was like, yeah, I love scars. And I was like, oh my gosh. And so I have this, you know, a fling. I don't even know what it was that was going on between us.
But she had the, it's a Rolex watch. and for whatever, oh, we had exchanged watches. She had a Rolex. I had a Timex and just one of those little plastic digital watches. And so we exchanged watches while we were having our fling or whatever was going on. And then when it ended, I went to give her her watch back, and she said, I want you to keep that. And I was like, oh, I can't keep your Rolex. And she was like, I want you to have it. And I was like, wow. And so I walked away with a
Rolex. Wow. Yeah. That is an amazing story. And she does like scars. I will confirm. It's really under scars. You got the gift of this person being completely, truly, like, turned on and attracted to you in this new form that you were so insecure about. And you got to a luxury watch out of this relationship. I am not. I don't think it gets better than that. No. And I am not somebody that, I'm just, I never would have bought a Rolex. Right. Yeah. I'm in a, I realize driving here, I'm in a flannel, not a flannel. What is this? Like a ribbed, long sleeve thermal. Yeah. That's inside out. I thought, you know what? When you sat down, I thought it's either inside out or that's the fashion. No, it's inside out.
So my sons always wear their shirts inside out. I'm always like, on purpose? No. Yeah. Not my buddy. There is a look. There is a fashion where the shirt is made to look inside out. Well, that's not what's happening.
But what's giving it away, though, is I can see on your chest that there is some writing that is backwards. And I think I'm meant to be able to read it. And let me just tell you, I will be 54 on the 24th of March and when's your birthday? June 25th. I'll be 54. Oh, well, my son's, their birthday, is June 26. Hey. Hey, we got to that point. We got birthdays. I still get excited about stuff like that. I'm like, anyway. But so, okay, so you're going to be 54. And I am somebody's parent. And I walked out of the house and circled the block. But can I just tell you unrelated, but related to being someone's parent this morning, our son, was called out and to speak at the school. Like the circle time? Assembly.
Okay. And he got interviewed in front of people at the assembly. And Stephanie and I were there this morning. And they said, is there a woman in your life that is inspiring to you? And he said, my two moms. And it was just like, and I was like, I'm, I'm. I'm always scared. I'm not going to be included in that because, you know, I go on to war. Wait. Well, no, you've told stories. You've shared so many funny stories where, like, you come home and they're like, oh, it's her. Oh, it's her. Oh, yeah. Well, this is the other one. Okay. Yeah. But I was like, I was included in that. And it was so sweet to hear him say, like, my two moms, I love them. And I love being a part of our family. And we were just like, Stephanie turned. She said, did that make you cry? And I was like, yes.
I didn't think I was going to be included. So anyway, I had to throw that in. It was such a nice little moment this morning. All that matters are those moments. That's it. That's all you think of in the quiet times are those moments. Yes. Whenever your kids do that thing.
Yes. Like the version of that thing, it just, I'm a puddle. Same. Same. All right. I would like to ask you to our call sheet questions. Okay. These were questions that were on the back of our call sheets.
Okay. And we would, different crew members would get asked each week and then we'd get to read their answers. It was really cool. We'd find out a little something about people that we worked with. Okay. Number one. What was your first entertainment job? Well, before I got into stand-up, I mean, as I mentioned, I think before I'm really into music.
And I play music, but I also, um, My first girlfriend had a band, and I started booking her band. And so... You were like an agent. I was a booking agent. And I also worked for a record company as a local person when I was living in Denver who would promote their bands. It would come through. I'd have to go hang up flyers and posters and go talk to record stores, make sure they were all their merch and stuff was in.
there. And so, yeah, that was my first entertainment job. I love it. I didn't know that. Well, now you know. No, I know. Yeah. This isn't interesting. I have a song I would like to play. No, I'm kidding. Maybe you could get behind. This is a pretty easy segue into our second question, which is do you play a musical instrument? You said you do. I play two. I play guitar and drums. And I'm, um, I'm very good. I'm. better at guitar. I think I'm more natural at drums, but I haven't had time to, I have more of an interest in drums as an adult. You know, if a guitar is sitting around, I could pick it up and play some stuff. But I want to get better. I want to take some lessons and get better at drums. Do you play any, like the guitar or anything for your kids? I mean, we have instruments
at the house and I've played stuff, but they're kind of, we also have a drum set. set. And it seems like they're more interested in the drums at the stage. Yeah. That tracks. Yeah. It's kind of easy to bang around. And this will make no sense if you haven't seen it. But you can see me play drums on my Netflix special. I'm happy to be here. Okay. Yeah. So that's for the listeners. If they would like to see me play the drums. I'm writing it down. I do our social media tag. So I'm going to put a little swipe up to that. Okay. Our next question is, what's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? Ah. There's so many places, and Stephanie makes fun of me because I've toured, I mean, I've been doing stand-up almost 30 years, and I go around the world, I go to small towns,
college towns, big cities, everywhere. And there is. not a place that I don't love. I mean, I really, where are you from? I was born in Louisiana, but my family's from Louisiana and Texas. Oh, okay. Okay. Yeah, I hear it. But I grew up in Indonesia, so it's weird. It is weird. I know. Yes. But you're like, it is weird. It is. I confirm. Yes. I mean, just the other day, Oklahoma came up and I was like, oh, I love Tulsa. And Stephanie was like, what? And I was like, I do. And then Indiana, It's like I love Bloomington. There are so many places that I love, and I do not write any state off or little town because of anything.
Because there are – I'm originally from Mississippi. Mm-hmm. And – 501? 601. 601. Yeah. I was close.
Yeah, you were. My aunt was in Mississippi, and my dad always called her 601. That's it. I'm a 601er. But I remember leaving, I was in Jackson, getting some award from the governor. And I was with my stepfather and my brother, and we were walking out of this restaurant. And this guy ran out of the restaurant, chases me down. And he thanks me for representing Mississippi in a positive way.
And he said, we're not all like what people think. He was like, and he was just, he was just so. genuinely thankful and it was such a reminder that there are incredible people everywhere and regardless of who's representing your city, state, country, there are people that are just tremendous and make these cities cool and great in the little pockets and the towns that you think, oh, there's nothing going on here. And so I just, I really do have such an appreciation for so many places. And I do love Tulsa and Bloomington.
And Iowa City, I love so many places. Do you do the same? Because wherever we go, my husband teases me about this. It doesn't matter where we go, I immediately am like on Redfin. I'm like, okay, how do people live here? Where do they live? What do their homes look like? I'm like so curious.
Yeah. And then you find those towns where you can get like an eight-bedroom house. I know. It's like what on earth? Have like. barn and, yeah, two barns, yeah, you know. I also, I'm a vegan person, which shifted after I got sick. I've changed my diet, and that's part of the fun of touring for me as well, is I have this
app called Happy Cow and you just put in wherever you are. And it tells you the nearest vegan restaurants. Really? Oh, my gosh. And when people are like, well, I live in this place and I can't, I'm like, no, no, no, I have Happy Cow. And I, because it gives you vegan options, and then if there aren't any, and then it goes to vegetarian.
And so it kind of goes down the, down the line. Yeah. And so I can always find something somewhere. Happy cow, folks. Happy cow. You heard it here. But I love, it makes touring so fun for me to find new vegan restaurants and options. Yeah.
That leads into our next question. It does? Wow. Number five. Oh, no, it doesn't. Number four. Never mind. doesn't hold that thought. Well, can't we do five and then do four? No. Oh, I'm kidding. No, we could. Do we
want to do that? Do we want to shake it up? Shake it up. All right. Question number five, what's your favorite midnight snack? Well, I'm rarely awake at midnight. Yeah, I know. This could be your favorite, like, I'm watching TV snack, too. Your favorite, Indulgence. Well, that's what I was going to say is, I mean, it's not a crazy indulgence, but our son, and I'm not saying this because I'm sitting here with you, too. But our sons, and I understand friends is not the office, but our sons got really into friends when we were on vacation. We would let them watch it if we were in a hotel room. And then it, for some reason, after this last summer, transferred over to our house where, every night we watch friends and have popcorn. And it's a whole family situation of watching an episode of friends before bed. And we're at season five. And after we finish friends, we're going to the office. And we're going to watch the entire run of the office. And that's because their grandfather is into the office. And he's who started showing them the office when
they were four. And so now that they're watching, you know, iconic sitcoms, the offices are next in line to plow through. If you need Pam and Angela to wish them a happy birthday, we will. We will make a video. That would be amazing. Yes. All right. Number four. What do you like to do on the weekends? I mean, because my career is so all over the place of recording my podcast of recording my podcast and doing shows and acting and whatever. A weekend is kind of a weekday. It doesn't. What is the weekend? As the Dowager says. Yes. Downton Abbey. Anyone? Anyone? No. No. What is the weekend? Okay, never mind. Forget it. She's saying it for a different reason, though. She's saying it because she lives a life
of leisure. Right. She doesn't know what the weekend is. It's true. This is the opposite. This is the opposite of that. Yeah. True. Well, yeah. And I have my relationship. and children, and then I'm just a person alive on the planet, too, and so I have my own things I want to do. So I am busy, but because I'm not on tour and because I'm not filming right now, my favorite thing to do is walk around the house saying, I'm a normal person, just having a normal day, just doing normal things. I'm a normal person. It's the most uncatchy song, but I love being home, just like going to baseball and basketball, perhaps, and then having a snack and shuffling around the house.
And I just, I am in heaven. Yeah. And then I just start singing the uncatchy song of, I'm a normal person, live in a normal life, do a normal thing. Like laundry. Yeah. And I love it. So it's weekends or weekdays.
But when I'm not like back to back with things, I have to do. And then this Zoom is over and then I have to do this interview and then I have to go And then I have to leave for the airport. And I, like, when it's like that, and I'm really trying to step away from that chaos. That pace is hard to keep up. It's really hard to keep up. And yet I find sometimes we set boundaries and we're not going to get sucked into it. And then we do.
And then we're like, gosh, how did we get sucked in? Well, because you have weak boundaries. That's how it happened. Because I'm a normal person. I'm at home doing normal things because I'm normal and I'm loving my life. Oh, Tigg, we love you. And I, you. Thank you for coming and talking with us.
Thank you for having me. Yes. The one thing we didn't talk about is your handsome podcasts. That's what I was about to say. We love. Okay. Well, you're both yelling at me. No, but we do. I mean, Cassie is wearing a baseball hat right now that says, little cowboy.
Uh-huh. Yes. It's a silly show. So you have Fortune, who's so funny. And May. I met Fortune. We were both on a panel for that show to tell us. the truth. And she was so incredibly funny. And I just, I love her on the Insta. I keep up with
her there. Same. Silly, silly, silly. And part of... I just love listening to you guys chat. Well, thank you. It's kind of like what I was saying before, how I was dealing with serious things all the time and trying to be helpful and supportive. And it almost became, as they say, a brand. which is great and fine. But I was also like, I want to just be stupid with some comedian pals. Yeah. And so that's what sparked handsome. And, you know, we're not a political show.
We're not, I mean, sometimes we have genuine questions that come in from people. And you guys should submit a question as well. Oh, yeah. We'll do that. I'll submit a question. Yeah, please do. You know, some, it just really runs the gamut of the questions that we get from people. And mostly we spin it into nonsense, but sometimes, you know, we'll ride an authentic, genuine wave of a response.
Yeah, we should tell everyone listening, when you go check it out, because it's fantastic, you guys have banter at the top, and then you have a question that has been sent in by someone, Jimmy Fallon, or. you know, whatever. There's people from all over that send in questions. And then you guys all just kind of riff on what your answer would be to that. And it's really, really fun. And then we play the answer at the end. At the end. Because the guest also answers their own question. Yeah. But it's very free form chat. Yeah. Yeah. So. By three hilarious people. Oh, well, thank you. Yes. Who all have, one of the benefits is you guys all have very. distinctive voices. It's very easy to tell who's talking. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. And we're also, May is in their 30s, fortunes in her 40s. I'm in my 50s. I have kids. I mean, I'm married with kids.
Fortune's married. May is single and really getting out there mingling. Yeah. And there's a lot of differences and cultural references that one of you will know and the other won't. And Cassie was mentioning that before you got here, that she liked that the three different voices were in different sort of places in their lives. Yes. Oh, TIG, one more thing before we go. Will you please tell us about the documentary you produced? I produced a documentary called Come See Me in the Good Light. And it is about my dear friend, Andrea Gibson, of 25 years, the poet laureate of the state of Colorado, who has state.
for ovarian cancer, and this film is so beautiful. It went to Sundance this year. And we all rented an Airbnb. It's produced by, you know, Glennon Doyle, Abby Wombach, Sarah Borellis, Brandy Carlis, Brandy Carlis. Everybody's just massive Andrea Gibson fans. This person is, it's poetry that is so accessible that will inspire you and destroy you and make you, it'll just blow your mind. Just such a talent. Anyway, we all go to Sundance. Andrea's not doing great. And we just went to the screenings, standing ovations.
You hear people sobbing through the screenings. The funny parts, it's like it could be a Will Ferrell movie. People are laughing so hard. And we were like, wow, this screened really well. But we didn't have the typical Sundance experience because we would go back to our Airbnb that we all were staying in and have tea, sit by the fire, hang out with Andrea and their partner Meg, who is also a poet in the film as well. And we went to the screenings. We weren't going to the parties and the events. And then we leave.
And we're just like, this went so well. It screened so well. And then I get home to Toronto. My phone is exploding. Can you get on a call? Hey, you know, and Meg called me directly as well, Andrea's partner. And I immediately was like, oh, God, this is bad. And I call Stephanie, and I'm like, I'm so scared to return this call.
So I mean, like, just call back. And I'm like on the edge of like losing my mind. I'm so scared to return this call. And I call Meg answers the phone. And Meg and Andrea are like, did you hear the news? And I was like, what? We won the Sundance Festival. Oh my gosh.
Not just in documentaries. It won the top award of Sundance this year. Oh my gosh. I then was in tears of joy. I was so confused because we didn't get a vibe. of how the movie was going. Yeah, because you were in your little sanctuary away. Snuggle down.
We were just like having snuggle down. And that was all we were doing. And our director who did the documentary Pamela, I don't know if you saw that of Pamela Anderson. He did the Serena Williams doc, the Dr. Ruth doc. But he was like, movies like ours do not win Sundance. And so, and it's sold and it'll be coming out later this year. But it's such a beautiful film.
Oh, I can't wait to see it. It screened at the Boulder Film Festival, and it just won that festival as well. Wow. Last night, we just got the news that it won that as well. So it's really, really, you walk out the door and you want to go live your life like you've never lived it before. It's incredible. Wow. Amazing.
Anyway, thank you for having me. Thank you so much, Tig, for being here and just being you. We just, we're so happy to have this time with you. Same. And I'm glad you're doing well. And I hope you're doing well. I am. Good.
Thanks. Yeah. Right. Now we're going to end in a whisper. I guess we should bring it back here. Okay. For sure. Just feels like we should.
Yeah. Okay. All right. Bye. Thanks. Thank you. Well, a big thank you to TIG Nataro for coming in the studio to chat with us. And thank you to everyone who wrote in today such great questions for TIG.
And you can find out more about TIG and her schedule of shows on her website, TIGNation.com, and be sure to check out her comedy special Hello Again on Prime Video. It's so funny. So funny. There's also her podcast, Handsome and, of course, Star Trek Starfleet Academy. And since we recorded this interview, TIG's friend and poet Andrea Gibson, very sadly, passed away over the summer. And this episode was recorded back in March. Yes.
And we can all honor and celebrate Andrea's story in the beautiful. beautiful documentary, come see me in the Good Light, coming to Apple Plus on November 14th. Yes, and I'll be sure and share it in our stories. Thanks again, everyone, for writing in. Thank you, TIG, and we will see you all next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.